lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
hablar de factores y de pares de
factores
cuando hablamos de factores nos
referimos a números que pueden
multiplicarse entre sí para formar otros
números por ejemplo si hablamos de los
factores de 6 puedo multiplicar 2 por 3
para obtener 6 por lo que decimos que 2
y 3 son factores de 6 de hecho podemos
decir que 2 y 3 es un par de factores de
6 porque cuando multiplicamos estos dos
nos da 6 y para pensar en todos los
pares de factores de un número podemos
pensarlo en términos de áreas como
podemos hacer un rectángulo de área 6
podemos hacerlo con 2 unidades por 3
unidades por lo que se ve como esto que
voy a dibujar a mano este rectángulo
tiene dos renglones y tres columnas y
digamos que todos tienen la misma área y
pueden ver que el área de aquí es 2 x 3
que es igual a seis unidades cuadradas
de qué otra manera podemos tener un área
de 6 podemos tener algo que sea de un
renglón y que tenga 6 columnas por lo
que luce más o menos
tiene un renglón y tiene una dos tres
cuatro cinco y seis columnas uno por
seis también da un área de seis este
sería otro par de factores sabemos que
dos por tres es igual a seis y que 1 por
6 es igual a 6 y estos son los dos pares
de factores para 6 podemos hacer esto
con números más grandes podemos pensar
en todos los pares de factores para 16
pausa en el vídeo y piensen en esto
vamos a dibujar una tabla aquí para
ayudarnos a pensar en esto en esta
columna pondré el primer factor y en
esta otra pondré el segundo factor y la
forma en que me gusta hacerlo es
comenzar en 1 e ir aumentando hasta 16
para tratar de encontrar todos los
factores
comenzamos con 1 y uno definitivamente
divide a 16 cualquier número es
divisible entre 1 que tengo que
multiplicar por 1 para tener 16 pues lo
tengo que multiplicar por 16 por lo que
aquí tenemos un par de
1 y 16 y que hay de 216 es divisible
entre 2 claro que sí
2 por 8 es igual a 16 este es otro par
de factores 2 por 8 y 33 puede dividir
exactamente a 16 pues no 3 por 5 es 15 y
3 por 6 es 18 así que tres no es factor
de 16 y que hay de 4 pues 4x4 es 16 por
lo que este es otro par de factores 4 y
4 y 5 bueno
5 por 2 es 10 5 por 3 es 15 5 por 4 es
20 por lo que cinco no divide
exactamente a 16 lo mismo pasa con 6 6
por 2 es 12 6 por 3 es 18 por lo que
tampoco divide exactamente a 16 y 77
tampoco divide exactamente a 16 7 por 2
es 14 7 por 3 es 21 y que hay de 8
ya sabemos que 8 divide exactamente a 16
y quizá nos veamos tentados a decir que
tenemos otro par de factores 8 por 2
pero ese ya lo habíamos anotado
solamente que habíamos puesto a 2 como
primer factor y 8 como segundo factor
pero lo podemos intercambiar y ya que
llegamos a la mitad podemos confiar en
que ya encontramos todos los pares de
factores podemos continuar con nueve
pero 9 no divide exactamente a 16 10
tampoco lo hace y tampoco 11 12 13 14 y
15 16 sin duda es divisible entre 16
pero ya lo habíamos escrito en este par
de factores por lo que tenemos tres
pares de factores 1 y 16 2 y 8 y 4 y 4